Trascrizione: Federico Sangati
Revisore: Marco Caresia
C'era una volta un bambino,
un bambino senza sogni.
Era un bambino che
viveva in una famiglia,
una famiglia come tante,
con i suoi pregi e con i suoi difetti.
Ma comunque una famiglia.
Era in compagnia di un fratello,
il fratellone,
quello un pò più grande,
colui che lo proteggeva.
Aveva degli amici, andava all'asilo,
era spesso dagli azzurri.
In realtà lui era dei rosa
però faceva sempre casino
e lo mandavano dagli azzurri.
Lì conobbe quello che è diventato poi
il suo migliore amico.
Lo era lì in asilo e lo è tutt'ora.
Questo bambino non aveva sogni:
giocava a calcio, era anche bravino
però c'era da far fatica.
Lì aveva vinto perfino il campionato
provinciale, però non aveva sogni.
Crebbe, finì la scuola.
La scuola era una prigione per lui.
Non ce la faceva a star dentro,
era uno spirito libero.
Voleva uscire da questa cosa che si
chiamava scuola, voleva vivere la vita.
Ma continuava a non avere sogni.
Fino a che andò a fare il militare.
Era fatto così: era più forte di lui.
Stava per mettere la firma,
voleva rimanere dentro;
ma proprio questa parola “dentro”
non ce la faceva.
E quindi se ne uscì, andò a lavorare
e fece 15 lavori:
dal macellaio, all'elettricista,
al muratore, al portalettere.
Fece di tutto
e sempre con quella voglia di arrivare.
Però non aveva un sogno, non sapeva dove.
Finchè gli venne una piccola idea:
fare l'animatore turistico.
Sarebbe bello fare l'animatore turistico!
Ma qualcuno gli disse:
"Eh... ma devi sapere l'inglese!"
E quindi andò a Londra a 25 anni
a lavorare in un ristorante francese
per imparare l'inglese.
E lo imparò,
faceva il lavapiatti e poi pian piano
è riuscito a diventare perfino
il capo della cucina,
perché lassù se sei bravo
te lo fanno capire.
E poi però a 25 anni aveva già 25 anni
e questo bambino
che aveva quest'idea dell'animatore
disse: "Ma perché ormai ho 25 anni
e sono vecchio: forse è il caso
che torno a casa e che mi trovo un lavoro
e che rimango lì a fare quello
che ho sempre fatto."
E così è ritornato a casa
e ha ritrovato il suo lavoro
e ha messo in parte
quello che era un sogno.
Poi un giorno una persona gli disse:
"Ma tu cosa vuoi fare da grande?"
E il bambino gli rispose:
"Voglio fare l'animatore turistico!"
"Ah, e perché non lo fai?"
"Eh... perché...", e trovò mille scuse.
E poi gli disse:
"Va bene ma da grande cosa vuoi fare?"
"L'animatore turistico", rispose.
"E perché non lo fai?"
"Eh... perché..."
Trovò altre mille scuse.
E allora gli chiese:
"Ma cosa vorresti fare da grande?"
Alché il bambino disse:
"Forse non l'hai capito,
ti ho detto l'animatore turistico!"
Lei lo guardò e gli disse:
"Forse non l'hai capito tu!"
Queste parole lo toccarono.
Andò a fare veramente
l'animatore turistico, mollò tutto.
Tutto quello che era sicurezza,
stare a casa, genitori, fratelli, amici.
E andò in un villaggio turistico a
Metaponto in Basilicata,
per 350 euro al mese.
Non c'è una persona che gli ha detto:
"Bravo, bella scelta!", immaginate...
E in quel villaggio
questo bambino grande,
com'era stato soprannominato
da un altro bambino,
conobbe delle persone speciali:
Giorgino, Beppe, Bart, e Roberta
quella persona che ad oggi
è diventata sua moglie.
E grazie a lei
è venuto a vivere in Trentino,
ha incominciato a lavorare,
a fare l'animatore turistico
lavorava negli alberghi,
lavorava per le piazze,
faceva la tombola,
faceva il karaoke.
E poi conobbe la magia
e lì cambiò tutto.
Il sogno cominciava
veramente a realizzarsi.
Stava facendo l'animatore turistico,
ma voleva far di più, voleva
parlare con le persone,
voleva comunicare con le persone
con dei mezzi.
Il mezzo era ridere e scherzare e studiò.
Studiò e cominciò a fare cose un po'
strane, si vestiva in maniera particolare,
faceva il clown, faceva un po' di tutto.
Quella è stata l'opportunità
che si è dato.
Si è permesso (che è una parola
che tanti non si permettono di fare),
lui si è permesso di divertire
e far divertire le persone.
Ed ecco che un giorno,
il 22 novembre 2014,
questo bambino
ha realizzato il suo sogno:
era su un palco a Trento al TED
a fare un numero di magia
per comunicare con le persone
e quello che voglio fare adesso
è questa cosa qua:
comunicare con voi tramite un filo.
È un filo che definisco:
il filo della bella vita.
Eccola questa è la bella vita:
bella perfetta dritta.
Guardate che meraviglia!
Ogni tanto capitano quegli alti e bassi,
succede questa cosa qua.
Ma poi se uno ha la forza ritorna
ad averla bella dritta perfetta così.
Ma per averla così abbiamo bisogno
di ingredienti particolari,
degli ingredienti che si chiamano valori.
Gli abbiamo visti prima
durante quel racconto
di quel bambino che ero io, Water Klinkon,
e ho espresso dei valori
e ho visto che è veramente importante
guardare i valori.
Ne elencherò alcuni perché
credo che sia importante.
Il primo valore è il valore dell'amore.
Poi ce ne sono altri tipo
l'onestà e il rispetto.
Potremmo nominare anche un altro che mi
piace assai che si chiama l'entusiasmo.
L'entusiasmo io lo definisco il valore
che ci dà l'opportunità di alimentare
tutti gli altri valori.
Nel momento in cui le cose magari
vanno un po' meno bene.
Un altro, venuto fuori in questi giorni,
si chiama proprio permesso.
Alle volte non bussate alla porta
ma entrate!
Perché se ti dai il permesso
di fare delle cose
riuscirai ad arrivare
dove non avresti mai pensato.
Ce ne sono tanti di valori.
Ah, una cosa importante: i valori
non vanno solo detti, non è solo un nome;
bisogna dargli un significato
e bisogna avere degli atteggiamenti
per far sì che quel valore
sia veramente un valore.
Un valore particolare che mi piace
si chiama cambiamento.
È un valore particolare perché per pochi
è un valore, per me è fenomenale.
Cosa vuol dire cambiamento?
Cambiamento vuol dire che,
se da quando sei nato fino ad oggi
hai fatto un certo tipo di vita,
se tu farai un cambiamento
aggiungerai qualcosa alla tua vita
e quindi da semplice cambiamento,
cioè sostituire,
per me cambiamento vuol dire aggiungere,
aggiungere alla mia vita.
Sì, perché è successo questo nel 2003,
io facevo il macellaio a Trieste,
in via Pirano 7,
in un piccolo supermercato
con mio fratello.
Mio fratello mi diceva delle parole
fenomenali, mi diceva:
"Per avere cose che non hai mai avuto,
devi far cose che non hai mai fatto."
Le parole erano veramente belle,
ma non sapevo dove metterle
fino a che incontrai quella persona che mi
disse: "Walter, cosa vuoi fare da grande?"
E quindi presi una decisione,
coraggio e decisione.
Mollai tutto, come vi dissi prima,
e andai a fare l'animatore turistico.
E oggi io nella vita sono un mago,
ma nel lavoro solo un illusionista.
Vi ho fatto vedere tante belle parole:
questo e quello che capita
soprattutto in TV oggi.
Ci fanno vedere delle cose,
ma rimangono lì così.
No! Io voglio fare qualcosa di più.
Non voglio lasciare le parole lì così
alla rinfusa e non farò neanche questo,
cosa che noi grandi siamo veramente
bravi a fare,
perché poi cresciamo
e ci dimentichiamo quello che magari
veramente volevamo.
Prendiamo tutte le belle parole
e le mettiamo qui
e le lasciamo così in sospeso
ma sì, farò domani, dopodomani,
fra un mese, un anno.
Poi alle volte passa una vita
e quello che veramente volevate fare
è rimasto lì, e quindi io questa sera
non lascerò niente in sospeso.
Lascerò un ricordo in voi che è quello di
prendere tutte le cose importanti
e metterle al centro della mia vita.
Perché al centro della mia vita?
Perché è quello il posto giusto,
perché io credo a quello che faccio,
credo nel prossimo,
ma credo in me stesso.
Io, nel ringraziarvi
di avermi dato l'opportunità
di poter comunicare con voi,
vi auguro a tutti quanti
una gran bella vita!
(Applausi)